大家好,
我是Jim,
這裡是AI Notebook,
今天這支影片會帶你走進史丹佛的一間教室,
這門課不教你怎麼訓練模型,
他問的是一個更少人問的問題,
你每天在用的這些AI,
背後那一整套東西到底是怎麼運轉的,
電從哪裡來,
機房誰去蓋,
錢誰出,
價值最後留到誰手上,
還有出事的時候,
站在法庭裡的會是誰。
這學期他們請了四個人
微軟的執行長
OpenAI的執行長
Google
關於基礎設施的技術長
還有一位前Uber的資安長
這四個人剛好站在
這條產業鏈的四個位置上
他們講出來的東西
有一個共同點
那也是我們今天
要一路追下去的線索
我們先從一句
聽起來很奇怪的話開始
2019年
微軟決定投資OpenAI
10億美元
六年之後
微軟的董事長
兼執行長Satya Nadella
坐在史丹佛的講臺上
被問到這個決定
他的回答繞開了那筆錢
他說你真正在分配的
從來不是資本
最大的那一個決定
是算力的集中
也就是說
這個時代的起點
是一次刻意的集中
把當時全世界
最稀缺的運算資源
壓在一個團隊
一個方向上面
而這門課請到的每一個人
包括他自己都在講
同一件他們害怕的事
權力不可以集中
在少數幾家公司手上
同一群人做了那件事
又在警告那件事
更奇怪的是
他們沒有一個人能說出
要怎麼避開它
這條矛盾就是我們今天要一路跟著走源的線索
我們先講清楚今天在看的是什麼
這門課叫CS153
Frontier Systems
中文可以說成前沿系統
是史丹佛2026年春季開的課
授課的是Angie Mita和Mike Abbott
兩個人都來自一家叫AMP的公司
Abbott
這個名字你可能沒聽過
但他做過微軟早期的雲端服務
當過Twitter第一任工程副總
也管過Apple的雲端
這門課從第一堂就把姿態擺得很清楚
不教你怎麼把模型訓練出來
他教你這一整套東西是怎麼運轉的
而最能說明他野心的
是期末專題的名字
叫The One Person Frontier Lab
一眼前沿實驗室
科網上寫的原話是
十週一個目標
為世界創造價值
看你能把自己放大到什麼程度
史丹佛正在教學生
怎麼一個人當一間實驗室
你今天要看的這四堂
就是他們請來的四個人
站在這條產業鏈的四個位置上
裡面的運作講給學生聽
我們從微軟的執行長
Satya Nadella開始
他這一堂是在
微軟開發者大會結束的
隔天盧德
人剛從舞臺上下來
訪談一開場就問了
那個所有人都想問的問題
2019年7月
微軟宣佈投資OpenAI11美元
那個決定是怎麼做出來的
你可能以為他會講一段
關於眼光的故事
他沒有
他說
任何時候你在分配稀缺資源
而很多時候
那個資源根本不只是錢
最大的那一個決定
是算力的集中
他的意思是
錢不稀缺
微軟賬上多的是錢
真正稀缺的是
當時全世界能拿來做這件事的運算資源
而他們決定不要平均分給100個專案
要壓在一個團隊身上
他還補了一段
很少有執行長會講的話
他說2017 2018年那個時候的微軟
其實不太相信深度學習
你那時候去問他們
他們會說某種符號邏輯
加上機器學習的組合
他說
我們大概不是最相信深度學習
能在語言上做出突破的那群人
所以那不是一個先知的決定
那是一個他們自己都還不確定的
那個賭注贏了以後
他現在在想的是另一件事
而這件事跟你上班的那家公司直接有關
他在課堂上問了一個很硬的問題
如果一個模型是從資料裡學會的
那公司這個東西的未來是什麼
他自己接著解釋
公司今天之所以值錢
是因為他在營運過程裡
累積下來的隱性知識
還有人生上的經驗
這些東西不寫在任何一份文件裡
它長在人跟流程中間
可是當這些東西越來越多被模型學走
公司還剩下什麼
他給的答案沒有留情面
他說
如果你只是一個基礎模型的消費者
我不確定你要怎麼保住企業價值
更別說創造價值了
你可以把這句話翻譯成一個很日常的畫面
你們公司花了15年
練出來的那一套做事方法
現在外面有一個買得到的工具
做得跟你們的直升員工一樣好
甚至更好
那你們公司相對於別人的優勢
還剩下幾成
這就是他要所有企業客戶正視的問題
所以他的解法是什麼
他用了一個很有畫面的詞
爬坡機
英文叫Hill Climbing Machine
聽起來很抽象
但他講的事情很具體
他要每一家公司把自己真正的工作流程
變成一個可以讓模型反覆練習的環境
再加上一份只有你有的考卷
這裡有兩個詞要先講白
第一個東西英文叫RL環境
中文是強化學習環境
你可以想成一間駕馴場
模型在裡面一直開
一直被扣分
一直重來
開到會為止
第二個東西叫Private Eros
私有評測
說白了就是一份只有你們公司有的考卷
任何一個新模型出來
你都可以把它丟進這座駕馴場練一輪
而練出來的那個變強的部分
歸你們公司所有
不是貴模型公司所有
微軟的賣點就是
你不用自己蓋這作家訊場
我們本來就在看你們怎麼跑流程
可以直接幫你生出第一批題目
這個判斷值得記下來
備來公司的護城河
可能不是你有多少資料
而是你有沒有一份
別人拿不到的考卷
有了這個判斷
他接下來做的每一件事
就都說得通了
微軟現在正在做一件
聽起來有點不像微軟的事
他想去用你筆記型電腦裡面
閒著的那一顆繪圖晶片
理由他講得很白
模型已經在那裡了
應用程式正在被寫出來
而Token供不應求
Token這個詞
你可以想成模型吐出來的字
一個Token
大概是一個詞或者半個詞
模型每講一句話都是燒它
它的意思是
需求已經大到雲端機房喂不飽了
所以它要把散在世界各地
每一臺電腦裡閒著的運算能力都利用起來
同一個邏輯還有第二個版本
微軟機房裡那些舊的繪圖晶片
沒有一臺被淘汰
他們把它們拿去加速資料倉儲
也就是幫企業跑報表和查詢的那一套系統
效能比原本快了好幾倍
它自己的說法是
我們把整個機隊當成一支雜牌軍來看
用軟體把每一臺的架子炸出來
你先把這個畫面記在心裡
等下第四位講者會從機房的那一端
講出一模一樣的事情
他也被問到
學生現在可以同時指揮100個coding agent
這到底是好事還是壞事
agent就是一個能自己動手做事的AI助理
你給他一個任務
他自己去查
去寫
去執行
他的回答沒有站隊
他發明了一個詞
認知覆蓋率
這個詞是從軟體測試借來的
工程師會算測試覆蓋率
意思是你的程式有百分之幾被測試檢查過
他把同一個問法搬到人身上
你指揮了100個agent
那你自己的腦袋覆蓋到了其中的幾成
他說重點根本不是你外包了多少
重點是你下了什麼指令
還有他做完之後
你看不看得懂他做了什麼
然後他給了一個學生一聽就懂的類比
這就像同時修100門課
你可以同時註冊100門
但期末你要考100次
這句話其實對每一個開始用AI工作的人都成立
你手上的產出變多了
但你能為他背書的那個比例
有沒有跟著變多
他還講了一句更硬的話
每個人都喜歡改變
只是他們希望改變的是別人
不是自己
他說重點不是把成長心態掛在嘴上
是有沒有勇氣正視自己身上
那個固定的部分
這一講最後的收束
是一個比喻
他引用了前一位講者的話
也就是我們等一下要講的
Sam Altman
連電力剛普及的時候
電力公司賣的不是電
是夜裡的燈
因為沒有人知道電是什麼
也不知道自己為什麼需要它
Nadella接下去那一句
是整堂課我印象最深的
他說而且那道光
不在AGI遊地區號裡的人看得見
AGI是通用人工智慧的縮寫
指的是那種什麼都會做的AI
他接著把話講得更重
他說這個生態系要是變成
少數幾家公司拿走全部報酬
其他人都過得很慘
那我們一定會失去社會許可
社會許可這個詞是說
一個產業能不能繼續做下去
最後不是法律決定的
是社會願不願意讓你做
請你先把社會許可這四個字放在心裡
等到第三位講者上場
你會看到那個許可被收回去的時候
具體長什麼樣子
第二位講者走進來的時候
這間教室對他來說是熟門熟路
Sam Altman
AI的執行長
他自己就是史丹佛一夜神
只念了兩年
2014年秋天
他還在這裡開過一門課叫How to start a startup
怎麼創一家公司
這門CS153的設計靈感之一
就是那門課
他一坐下來就講了一句很有意思的話
他說我剛剛走進來的時候在想
如果我再多一點時間
我也想把那門課整個重做一次
因為創業這件事的每一個環節都變了
我到現在還沒看過
有人做出一個好的
屬於現在的版本
順帶把一個
常常被講錯的年份講清楚
OpenAI成了於2015年12月
他在臺上先講了1015
又改口1016
正確的是2015
這場對談的主題
只有一個字
規模
而他要講的是
他這一輩子看過最重要
卻也最說不清楚的一個現象
他的核心信念是這樣的
當你把一個東西的規模拉大
它會長出在小規模的時候
完全不存在的性質
這個現象有一個名字叫湧現
意思是能力不是被你一項一項加上去的
是量做大的以後自己冒出來的
但他接下來的那一段
才是我覺得整堂課最誠實的地方
他說我不知道這個觀察為什麼是真的
我提不出任何一個
我自己滿意的理論來解釋它
這讓我有點緊張
緊張到我不太敢叫你們照做
但我還是要講
因為經驗上它就是成立的
你想想這句話的分量
今天全世界壓上幾千億美元
開機房買晶片籤電力合約
而背後那個最根本的信念
是一個世界上最瞭解他的人
自己說我解釋不了的東西
它不是一個理論
它是一條一直往上
還沒有轉彎的曲線
他說他真正學會這件事
其實不是在AI上面
是在Y Combinator
當年所有聰明人都叫他
把每一批新創的規模縮回去
但他發現真正的魔法
在同一批人彼此之間的互相幫忙
那個東西在只有10加的時候
根本不存在
它是規模長出來的
他講完信念之後
接著講了一個
很多人以為自己知道
其實不知道的故事
Check GPT是怎麼來的
GPT-3做出來以後
OpenAI內部找不到產品
他們不知道這個東西該長成什麼樣子
最後的決定是
開放成一個API丟出去
API你可以想成一個插座
外面的程式插上來就能用你的服務
他自己的說法是
希望別人想得出來
這個插座上線之後
在推特上很隨機的紅了一陣子
但真正跑得起來的生意只有一種
幫人寫行銷文案
他的評價是不怎麼樣
也不怎麼令人興奮
可是他們注意到了一個異常
一堆人拿了精藥之後
其實什麼正經事都沒做
他們只是在跟他聊天
這件事在報表上看起來像雜訊
是那種會被歸類成
使用者亂玩的東西
但他們決定認真對待這個雜訊
把那個聊天的界面單獨做出來
這就是ChatGPD的由來
它不是一個規劃出來的產品
它是一個失敗品旁邊長出來的東西
上線之後那幾天
他做了一個判斷
我覺得任何在做產品的人都該學起來
ChatGPD上線
流量每天往上衝
然後掉下來
每次掉下來
公司裡就有人說
你看吧 只是炒作
可是隔天他又衝到一個更高的高點
他說到第四天第五天
我就知道接下來會發生什麼事了
第五天他把所有人叫進來
講了一句很經典的話
這是緊急狀況
是好的那種緊急狀況
但我們同時把公司和產品系蓋出來
他判斷的依據
是他在Y Combinator
有活到的一條規則
當一個東西已經開始成長
而它其實還很爛
那你手上就是一個
幾乎保證會紅的東西
這句話的邏輯很簡單
用的東西紅了不奇怪
難用的東西還一直有人回來
那代表底下有一個很強的需求
強到願意忍受這麼糟的體驗
你如果現在手上有任何一個作品
這個判準筆
任何一份市場調查都好用
不過這一堂最值得被記住的
可能不是他講對的事
是他承認自己講錯的事
有人問他
這三年有沒有什麼是他預測錯的
他講了教育
他說ChatGPT剛上線的時候
我心裡想的是
好吧
大概會有一年學生拿他作弊
學不到東西
然後整個教育系統
就會重新設計自己
然後他停了一下說
老實講
ChatGPT上線三年半以來
我指不出任何一個體制性的改變
那是我的一個預測錯誤
他接著給了一個警告
如果一直這樣不改
會出現的是批判性思考能力的萎縮
這件事其實不只發生在學校裡
你自己想想
你上一次為了一個問題
坐在那裡想到頭痛
是什麼時候
現在的預測動作是打開一個對話框
他沒有把這件事講成末日
他只是誠實地說
我以為那個系統會自己調整
結果他沒有
而在這門課上
這句話還有第二層意思
一個從2015年就開始做這件事的人
對他的社會後果
預測能力也是有限的
他丟出了整場對談裡
我認為最重要一句
他說
一件很少被討論的事情是
我們具體要怎麼分配算力
這句話為什麼重要
因為算力已經不只是一個技術資源了
他決定誰能做研究
誰能做產品
誰家的小孩用得到好的家教
而他的判斷是
這個短缺不會過去
他的原話是
只要我們還能持續進步
短缺就會永遠存在
理由不是產能不夠
是需求根本沒有上限
他說
如果我們做出很好的個人助理
你會想同時跑10個
然後你會想跑100個
我覺得你真的會想要100個
現場有人說
這感覺像運算時代的疫情搶購
衛生紙全被買光了
他的回答是
我覺得大家應該要更恐慌一點
至於誰該拿到這些算力
他只給了一個偏好
沒有給機制
他說他更希望看到的
是人們持有某種所有權
而不是每個月固定領一筆現金
他講到這裡
自己把那個最大的分叉講了出來
他說未來10年最重要的一件事
是這個技術到底會民主化
讓很多人都用得上
也分得到
還是會集中到少數幾家公司手上
讓他們變成地球上財富的一大塊
他給了民主化這條路大概八成的幾率
但他馬上補了一個詞
那裡有一個吸引子狀態
吸引子狀態是物理和數學裡的講法
意思是一個系統只要靠得夠近
就會被那個狀態吸過去
你不用做錯什麼
你只要什麼都不做就滑進去
他說的最有力的是這一句
把這件事集中在少數幾家公司手上的風險
即使我們會是那少數幾家之一
也不是我們應該容忍的事
你注意他的位置
他是最有可能成為贏家的那個人
而他站在那裡說
這件事不該被容忍
可是他也承認
他沒有機智
他知道分配算力
是最少被討論的問題
他也知道那裡有一個
會把所有人吸進去的狀態
然後他沒有答案
這個空缺
就是接下來兩位講者
要從完全不同的角度
替他補上具體的形狀
而第三位講者一上臺
這門課的氣氛就變了
前面兩位在講
我們要蓋多大的東西
這一位在講
蓋這個東西的人
出事之後會怎麼被審判
我們先從2017年
感恩節那一週講起
他跟家人在泰浩湖度假
一位彭博社的記者
傳訊息給他
想跟他聊聊
他被Uber開除這件事
他看著手機
完全不知道對方在講什麼
因為沒有任何人
告訴過他這件事
一個小時之後
全球的新聞標題上線了
Uber付錢給駭客
刪掉5700萬人
被偷走的資料
然後是最像電影的一幕
他說
我的手機在那個當下
停止運作了
因為那隻手機
是Uber配給他的
而他自己的團隊
在上面裝了管理軟體
接著他的團隊
用那套軟體
他的手機和電腦
然後變成了兩塊磚
而那套軟體
是他自己導入公司的
他站在湖邊
手上拿著一塊
什麼都打不開的金屬
而全世界正在讀他的名字
這個人是誰
你必須先知道
才會知道這件事有多不合理
他叫Joe Sullivan
他的職業起點不是硅谷
是美國司法部
2001年到2002年
他在北加州的
聯邦檢察官辦公室
當檢察官
而且是那個辦公室裡
專門辦電腦入侵
和智慧財產案件的
小組的創始成員之一
也就是說
他這輩子第一份重要的工作
是起訴駭客
之後他去了eBay和PayPal
接著當了大約五年
Facebook的資安長
2015年被Uber找去當資安長
資安長這個職位
英文叫CSO
簡單講就是
一家公司裡負責
守住所有資料和系統的那個人
所以請你記住這個組合
一個當過檢察官的人
在做資安長
全世界最清楚
哪些事情會構成犯罪的
那一群人裡面
他是其中一個
而接下來發生的事情是
這個人在他自己
最守的那一條法律上
被定罪了
我們把時間往前拉一年
看那個案子到底是什麼
2016年秋天
有人寫信到Uber
說找到了一個嚴重的漏洞
他照著公司的標準流程
把信轉給負責漏洞獎金的
產品安全團隊
漏洞獎金這個制度
是科技公司公開
跟外面的研究者說
你找到我的問題來告訴我
我付你錢
讓你拿去黑市賣好
查下去之後發現
這個漏洞來自一個
很舊的雲端設定問題
而牽涉到的那個資料庫
是在他們到職之前
就已經被放著不管的
他的團隊根本不知道他存在
他們付了10萬美元的漏洞獎金
加上一份保密協議
這件事執行長簽了合
法務有兩到三位律師全程在回權禮
東關團隊也在
法務的判斷是
我們認為這件事不需要對外揭露
你可以不同意這個判斷
但請注意
這條路上的每一個環節
都有一個被授權的人籤的字
這也是整個故事最讓人不安的地方
他不是一個人在深夜裡偷偷做的決定
而且他做的比流程要求的還多
他不放心那兩個駭客
是不是真的把資料刪掉了
所以他派了一位
受過訓練的退役中情局訊問專家
飛到佛羅里達去當面確認
專家回來之後
交給他一份六頁的心理測寫
這裡還有一個對照組
讓整件事更難評價
同一批駭客
當時也去敲了另一家公司
LinkedIn
LinkedIn選擇了另外一條路
報警
結果是聯邦調查局
找不到這兩個人
他的團隊找到了
所以如果你只看結果
這個治安長做的事情是
找到了執法單位找不到的人
確認了資料被刪除付了錢
拿到保密協議
而且每一部都有法務背書
這一段講完
你大概會覺得這個故事應該就結束了
可是他才剛剛開始
2020年
聯邦調查局發了一份新聞稿
那一天他的大女兒
正在德州大學奧斯汀分校搬進宿舍
他的同學在收音機上聽到一則新聞
裡面有他爸爸的名字
他整個人慌了
打電話回家
而他本人那個時候
正坐在家裡的書桌前
開Cloudflare的視訊會議
他其實沒有被逮捕
但他被起訴了
罪名有兩條
我們把它翻成白話
第一條是
妨礙聯邦貿易委員會的調查程序
聯邦貿易委員會當時正在調查
Uber早年的另外一次資料外洩
檢方認為他沒有把這一次的事情交出去
第二條的英文很拗口
中文可以說成知情不報重罪
意思是你知道有一個重罪發生了
你不但沒有報告
還做了事情去掩蓋它
到這裡
事情已經從一個公司內部的判斷
變成了一個人要不要坐牢的問題
而全美國的資安長都在看這一場
案子在2022年9月開庭
他的律師在政府舉證員之後
跟他說了一句話
我們根本不用辯護
我們應定了
陪審團退籍之後
議了好幾天
然後他們遞出了一個問題
那個問題把整套辯護掏空了
他們問的是
依照美國那條電腦入侵法
Uber有沒有權利在存取
已經發生之後
回頭補一個授權
你可能覺得這聽起來很技術
但他決定了一切
因為如果公司可以事後授權
那兩個駭客拿走資料這件事
在法律上就變成了一次
被許可的存取
也就沒有那個重罪
可以被知情不報
他過去拿到的
所有法律意見都說可以
類比的是一條
很古老的侵入罪
有人走進你家前院
你在那當下說進來吧
在法律上就不再是侵入
可是法官不確定
政府主張不行
陪審團最後拿到的指示是
Uber不能授權
他自己的形容是
這基本上
把我們整套辯護掏空了
你注意這件事的形狀
不是他做錯了什麼
是那一條規則
在他做完之後
才被定義出來
判刑之前
聯邦的緩刑辦公室會做一份很厚的量刑前調查報告
這個過程裡
他收到了超過200封寄給法官的澄清信
其中一封有60個治安界的人聯署
另一封50個
另一封40個
他形容那段時間的說法我一直忘不掉
他說我等於是參加了自己的首領
我還活著的時候就聽到了所有人講我的好話
而最讓他震動的
是信裡寫的很多事情他自己完全不記得
1023年5月判決下來
政府原本要求三年聯邦監禁
後來降到18個月
法官說他最想聽到的一句話
這不是一場掩蓋
然後法官當庭訓斥了檢方
如果你要起訴一家公司
你為什麼不起訴執行長
執行長在迴圈裡
執行長支持了所有的決定
如果我們要讓公司負責
那就從最上面開始
最後他被判三年緩刑
200小時社區服務
加上5萬美元罰金
但這個故事沒有停在這裡
而且他在臺上沒有講
1025年3月
聯邦第九巡迴上訴法院
一致維持了他的有罪判決
所以他站在史丹佛講臺上的那一刻
法律上他仍然是一個重罪犯
這故事裡還有一個很亮的對照組
而且他自己就是主角
被全球媒體點名之後
第一批主動聯絡他
想請他去當治安主管的三家公司
是華為、WeWork和肢解跳動
他講這句話的時候特別強調
我是認真的
他最後選了當時還很小的Cloudflare
因為那家公司的執行長
Matthew Prince
打了電話去問他的前老闆
一定賭一把
到了Cloudflare之後的第一次治安事件
是一個星期五的晚上
他打給執行長報告
對方只問了一句話
誰寫部落格文章
他說我們現在在流血
對方又問了一次
誰寫部落格文章
五分鐘之後
技術長自己上了視訊會議說
我來寫
一年之後
Cloudflare推壞了一條防火牆規則
半個網機網路掛掉
隔天他上網看討論
看到的是這個
我們實質上弄壞了整個網機網路
結果大家在稱讚我們透明
他的結論很簡單
選擇透明的公司在累積信任
而選擇不透明的公司
累積的是慢慢主廢的負面情緒
他講完自己的故事
這是上集裡唯一一段從第一線看AF2D的內容
他服務過一家美國東南部的小銀行
兩個月之內
這家銀行每個月產出的城市碼
從25萬行變成125萬行
人數沒有變
變的是工具
然後他講了一件讓所有資安主管背脊發涼的事
灣區有一家公司的資安常打給他
說第一個把有漏洞的城市合併進正式環境的人
來自行銷部門
而傳統流程在這裡整個失效
因為資安部門的做法是把問題退回去
附上一個建議的修法
讓工程師自己看著辦
行銷部門的人做不到這件事
他們不會修
肥技術的員工也拿不到
公司的API金鑰
他們的解法不是去申請
是自己跑到外面架一臺伺服器
自己生一把出來
他的總結是我聽過最好的比喻
他說
公司裡的agent
就像家裡的學部幼兒
他們到處跑
他們跑得很快
然後每隔一陣子就會出事
你看過家裡有幼兒的父母吧
他們是跟在旁邊一起跑的
這就是我們現在得做到的事
及時
而且是在他動的當下
他也講了一個真實的規模參考
讓你知道這件事失手會長什麼樣子
2025年8月底
英國的Jaguar Land Rover被攻擊
三座工廠停產了大約5週
英國政府後來提供了最高15億英鎊的貸款擔保
而英國一個專門評估資安損失的機構估算
這件事對英國經濟的總成本大約是19億英鎊
是英國史上最具破壞性的資安事件
但真正的痛點不在車廠身上
這家公司的零件來自幾百家小公司
停產的那幾週
這些小廠交不了貨
收不到錢
很多撐不下去
他給學生的結論不是要更小心
而是這一句
我們不會把任性和危機管理
寫進職務說明書
但如果你2026年在科技業工作
你必須準備好被人一拳打在臉上
他接著補了那個比喻
拳擊手上場的時候
就知道自己會被打
但他還是有計劃
他甚至提到
勒索軟體談判員
現在已經是一個正式的職業
而業界的最佳做法
是先簽好一個放在快速撥號裡
第四位講者
是這個系列裡
技術密度最高的一場
他叫Amin Vade
Google的資深副總裁
也是AI與基礎設施的技術長
直接向執行長報告
他手上管的是TPU
也就是Google自己設計的AI晶片
還有資料中心的網路
機房的排成系統
還有整條供應鏈
他原本是大學教授
2010年用一年學術休假的名義加入Google
然後就沒有回去了
他一開口就否定了現在全世界正在用的那把尺
今天你看任何一則AI新聞
數的都是Gigawatt
Gigawatt的中文叫十億瓦
是一個電力的單位
你可以直接想成1GW差不多就是一部核能發電機組全開
用得起做中型程式
所有人現在都在比誰手上有幾GW
而他說的是
最重要的考量不是你有幾GW
是你交付給使用者多少能力和價值
然後他講的那句最關鍵的話
我這裡有一個GW
那裡有一個GW
咱們不是同一個東西
然後他要換成哪一把尺
他給的替代指標非常好懂
他說如果我在做Gemini這個應用程式
背後有1GW在跑
也是沒有人在乎
那背後是一個兩個四個還是半個
大家在乎的是
我有多少開心的日活躍使用者
日活躍使用者的意思是
每天真的打開來用的人
所以他要的計分板
是每Gigawatt
能換到多少開心的使用者
這個轉換聽起來很簡單
但他會改變一家公司所有的決策
他把同一件事再講得更硬一點
不是衡量標準
不是你每Gigawatt花了多少錢
是你每一塊錢交付了多少價值
如果我可以花一半的錢
部署一半的容量
給你一樣的能力
那太好了
更好的是
如果我能從同一個Gigawatt
交付兩倍的價值
我就少蓋幾個Gigawatt
這句話的分量在於他的方向
全世界都在講怎麼蓋更多
他在講怎麼少蓋
而他還有一句話
用一個工程師的詞
把這件事講到底
如果我們有容量在那邊閒著
那是一個bug
然後他講了一個
我認為是整支影片
最讓人恍然大悟的事實
過去20年
企業客戶要的可靠度
叫五個九
意思是小數點後面
扔著三個九
換算下來
這年只能停30秒
這個要求聽起來很合理
你當然不希望你的服務中斷
但他問了一個沒什麼人問的問題
這件事的代價是什麼
要做到五個九
電力系統必須做到雙分倍元
也就是每一條供電的路徑
旁邊都要有一條一模一樣的路徑顯著等
隨時準備接手
他的原話是
這代表任何時刻
你都有一半的電力容量沒在使用
你可以想成一臺永遠開著兩顆引擎的飛機
其中一顆從頭到尾只是在那邊空轉
為的是萬一另外一顆熄火
這就是為什麼他說計分板是錯的
當所有人在數這個國家又蓋了幾GW的時候
那些GW裡面有很大一塊
從一開始就不是拿來算東西的
它是拿來當保險的
可是這件事現在正在翻轉
而他把這個翻轉標成一個很值得注意的新發展
他說你現在去問那些前沿實驗是一個問題
你要兩倍的容量
但一年加起來會停機三天多
還是要一半的容量
但一年只停30秒
他們的回答是兩倍
那個算我一份
有更多容量
停機我認了
這是產業心態的一次地殼變動
過去20年
整個網絡服務業的信仰
是可用性至上
因為使用者一秒都不能等
但是訓練模型
看的是另外一個東西
叫吞吐量
就是同一段時間
你到底算完了多少
停一天
你損失的是一天的進度
不是一群客戶
這裡還有一個
很違反直覺的細節
訓練是一種同步計算
1GW的機房
大概是15萬到20萬顆晶片
而這些晶片
必須手牽手一起走
一顆倒下
這個計算就可能停住
他說
過去20幾年
網絡服務業建立起來的
就是別擔心單一臺機器壞掉
系統會自己繞過去
在這裡全部作廢
因為現在每一個節點都是特殊的
它負責的是模型裡特定的那一層
所以他們做了一件很像科幻片的事
Google的機房裡有一種設備
叫光路交換機
你先想象現在的網路長什麼樣子
資料在機器之間跑
中間要經過一臺一臺的交換機
每一臺都要把光訊號變成電訊號
讀懂它再送出去
這非常耗電
光路交換機不做這件事
它裡面裝的是一片會轉動的微型鏡子
總共136面
每一面都可以三維轉向
光從機櫃的光線射進來
打在鏡子上
被反射到指定的出口
全程沒有變成電
所以它的耗電只有大約100瓦出頭
而等級的傳統交換機要3000瓦
但真正厲害的是它能做什麼
當一整個機櫃壞掉
它不需要有人跑到機房裡去拔線
它只要把鏡子轉一個角度
就可以在幾秒鐘之內
把壞掉的機櫃從天上往裡拿掉
放上一個備用的
它的說法是
TPU真正的差異化
就是可以做到高得多的可用性
我現在可以瞬間從故障中恢復
我們講完機房裡面
把鏡頭拉到機房外面
這是他這一堂最現實的一段
1GW的資料中心到底要花多少錢
公開的估算差很多
看你算到哪一層
比較安全的講法是
350億到600億美元之間
這個數字你可以這樣感受
一座這樣的機房
價格是一整條高速鐵路的等級
而Google的目標是數十個GW
更難的其實不是錢
是時間
從決定要蓋到真的能用
前置期大概兩到三年
也就是說你以前就必須說出
你兩年之後確切需要多少容量
他把這件事講成一個沒有好答案的題目
他說基本上會有兩種結局
結局一你預測太少
你會非常懊惱
因為你把機會留在地上
結局二你預測太多
你剛剛浪費了一大筆錢
還有第三種幾率無限小的可能
你預測的剛剛好
那從來不會發生
他還舉了一個現成的例子
寫程式的agent是四五個月前才報起來的
沒有任何人在那個等級上預測到
所以沒有人有足夠的前置時間去準備機器
現在大家到處在問
我可以在哪裡弄到容量
而最能說明這件事
已經變成什麼樣子的
是他講的電力合約
他說
以前你去跟電力公司
要10MW
對方會說沒問題
連約都不用籤
我閒著的容量多的是
現在你去要1GW
對方的回答變成
沒問題
但你要簽約
接下來20年
一天24小時
你都得付這1GW的錢
這種合約有一個特性
用不用都要付
你可以直接想成
健身房的年費
你去不去他都照扣
只是這裡的金額
是一整座城市的電費
原因是電網上已經沒有多餘的備源容量了
電力公司必須確定你會付才敢為你蓋
這件事本身就是一臺把產業推向集中的機器
因為全世界能簽下那張紙的資產負債表不到10分
這裡還有一個副作用
因為超大規模的業者只要那種未來還能擴充的廠子
所以任何100MW以下的地點基本上都變成了孤兒
他自己的判斷是
等需求從訓練轉向日常使用
這件事會慢慢鬆開
因為日常使用可以切成小塊 比較好搬
供應鏈這條線上
有一段對臺灣觀眾特別有意思
他在課堂上順口說
團隊現在人在臺灣南岸泰國
這條鏈的一大段就在我們旁邊
然後有學生問了一個臺灣媒體
每天在講的問題
NVIDIA已經把臺積電的產能鎖住了
你們要怎麼辦
他沒有抱怨
他用對基本的道理
把這個前提化解掉
他說你想看
如果你是一家電容器的供應商
你會想要只有一個客戶嗎
就算這個客戶未來三年
要包下你全部的產能
就算他讓你賺更多錢
這對供應商其實不好
你去看任何一家公司的財報揭露
如果九成的營收來自一兩個客戶
投資人不會開心
也就是說
供應商自己就有很強的動機
不讓客戶集中
這是整個系列裡少數幾個
真的在對抗集中的力量
而且它靠的不是道德 是風險
另一個學生問
TPU什麼時候可以打敗GPU
他說這連目標都不是
就是市場擴張的太劇烈
沒有輸贏可言
而主持人接著給了全班一句更重的話
真實世界裡沒有贏家和輸家
只有把事情做成的人
和沒做成的人
這一堂最珍貴的部分
是兩段承認
第一段發生在2015年
他們在設計第二代TPU的時候
要選網路技術
當時整個產業
40幾年的共識是
網路就是用Ethernet
也就是我們平常在用的
以太網路
有一些很聰明的人跟他說
對
這個領域要的是另一種做法
Ethernet是錯的解法
他當時的反應是
搞什麼
我背後有40年的歷史
而且我和另外1000個人
一直都是對的
然後他在臺上說
錯了
TPU真的不該用Ethernet
這個判斷經受了十年的考驗
我搞錯了
而我學到了一件事
第二段更重
有人問他真正的瓶頸是什麼
他先說沒有單一的瓶頸
他每天都在換
然後他給了這場最誠實的一句
我最不知道解法的那一個是能源
他說要把能源擴張到我們全球需要的規模
方法都很貴
而且不只是錢貴
被追問哪些方向被低估的時候
他的答案樸素到不像一個技術長
風光電池
他說這是一個製造和規模化的過程
裡面有物理
而物理就是需要時間
他這一堂的最後回到了一件跟工程無關的事
Google的機房有兩種設計
一種比較省電但是要用很多水
一種幾乎不用水但是電銷差10%
他說10%很多
1GW省他10%
那是多出來的100MW
可是他做的決定是
除非那個社區的水真的很充裕
否則一律走比較耗電
幾乎不用水的那種
他還講了另外一個做法
電網我在一年裡最冷或最熱的那一軸
必須過度建設
所以他們跟電力公司說
等那兩天你告訴我們
我們把資料中心關掉
把100MW還給你
他說我們很樂意接受那個停機
然後是他這一場的最後一句
那個Gigawatt
不是某個人試算表裡
一個抽象的Gigawatt
它是在猶他州的一次大規模部署
它必須是那個社區的資產
你有沒有發現
這句話跟第一位講者說的
社會許可
其實同一件事情的兩端
我們把四個人放在一起看
他們表面上完全不相干
企業策略 創業哲學
一場官司 機房工程
可是他們咬得很緊
這個時代的起點
是一次刻意的集中
微軟的執行長親口說
最大的那一個決定不是那筆錢
說了算力的集中
而現在同一群人
每一個都把集中值認為失敗模式
OpenAI的執行長說
即使我們會是那少數幾家之一
這也不是該容忍的事
微軟的執行長說
如果變成少數幾家拿走全部報酬
我們會失去社會許可
可是Google那位管基礎設施的人
把物理現實攤開來
一座機房350億美元起跳
前置期兩到三年
還要籤一張20年的電力合約
RCA簽得起那張紙的
不到十份
也就是說
集中不是誰的陰謀
它是條件本身長出來的結果
最有權利的三個人
一致說不要集中
但沒有一個人能說出
避開他的機制
OpenA的執行長自己承認
最早被討論的問題就是
算力要怎麼分
然後他沒有答案
而第三位講者告訴我們
問題一直沒有答案
最後會發生什麼事
不是一場辯論
是一個人站在法庭裡
而法官在問
如果要讓公司負責
為什麼不是執行長
前四講走遠
你會發現這四個人
其實在回答同一個問題
這一整套東西
該由誰蓋
有誰付錢
又該由誰負責
微軟的執行長說
真正的賭注
從來不是那筆錢
是算力的集中
OpenAI的執行長說
就算自己會是贏家
集中也不該被容忍
Google的技術長
把賬單攤開來給你看
那張20年的電力合約
全世界簽得起的不到10分
NiFi前置案長
是唯一一個
真的站到法庭裡的人
他告訴我們
當責任的規則還沒寫好
最後被寫進判決書的
會是一個人的名字
最後問你一個問題
如果你可以在這四堂課裡選一堂
坐在教室裡把手舉起來
你會問哪一位
問什麼
留言告訴我
終甲我們會接著看
AI原生的公司怎麼運作
還有算力和能源的瓶頸
到底卡在哪
我會放在同一個播放清單裡
喜歡的話訂閱AI Notebook
開啟通知
我們下次見